here in the Yaak Valley of northern
Mexico farmers are busy tending their
wheat like most thriving agricultural
communities these farmers benefit from
fertile soil and irrigation but the main
reason that nearby ciudad obregon has
grown into a thriving city and the
breadbasket of Mexico is because of the
research of Norman Borlaug more than 60
years ago he created Hardy plants that
could resist a virulent fungus called we
trust I have seen the misery that comes
from rust epidemics and other foliar
diseases but the rust are unique because
they are carried by the wind her own
distance during the summer seasons
Borlaug's varieties boosted yields and
they helped keep hundreds of millions of
people from starving for that work for
log won the Nobel Peace Prize in 1970
and this spring at 94 years old he
journeyed back to ciudad obregon here
where it all started the reason Borlaug
is back is because he's leading a
worldwide effort to combat a new and
dire threat to wheat production a
dangerous new type of stem rust appeared
in Uganda 10 years ago and scientists
around the world are trying to come up
with new varieties of wheat that can
survive it the new fungus has already
spread to Kenya and Ethiopia where it is
now regularly found in the moist
Highlands spores have turned up as far
as Iran and likely will spread even
further east to india and pakistan where
untold numbers of subsistence farmers
grow wheat Ronnie Kaufman of the Borlaug
global rust initiative says an outbreak
there could have terrible consequences
and it will mean the loss of lives and
livelihoods for literally millions of
people if it catches fire in the wrong
place at the wrong time when Kaufman
says catching fire he's talking about
the ability of rust to produce massive
numbers of spores that spread with the
wind these spores take a harsh tool on
susceptible plants infected they become
almost worthless we
shriveled grain that no one buys while
fungicides can help stop the rust if
applied early enough they are too
expensive for many farmers last time
Borlaug dealt with such a problem
starting in 1944 he found many wheat
farmers in Mexico had given up on their
fields because of stem rust or log
worked here in ciudad obregon and
devised an innovative scheme that cut in
half the amount of time needed for
breeding and so by the early 1960s he
and his colleagues had created
disease-resistant varieties of wheat
that dramatically boosted wheat yields
around the world they sent the varieties
to India and Pakistan which were
struggling with famine breeders they're
adapted the wheat to local conditions
and the new crops grew and the famine
subsided manggarai is the
director-general of the Indian
Agricultural Research Council this all
put together made a tremendous
difference in enhancing productivity and
production of weed in the country as a
whole so successfully over three to four
decades we have been able to manage the
rest- but now this new kind of fungus
has hit hard for example last year in
Kenya some farmers lost up to eighty
percent of their harvest back in 2005
Borlaug visited Kenya that's when he
launched his global rust initiative to
help combat the threat of this new we
trust hans brown heads up the wheat
breeding program at the international
maize and wheat improvement center if
there had not been dr. Borlaug with his
global recognition and reputation i'm
not sure the world really would have
reacted the way I did this past March
more than 300 scientists met along with
Borlaug in ciudad obregon to discuss the
progress so far and tour experimental
fields Ravi Singh a wheat breeder at the
international maize and wheat
improvement center says several
varieties of wheat carry genes for
powerful resistance to this latest
fungus but one in particular named King
bird is especially useful the thing it
would protect lot of new whether it is
by giving this the distance at kellys so
he and his team are sending out seed for
testing and further improvements in
other countries
but much more breeding and testing needs
to be done and dealing with this latest
form of virulent we trust won't be the
end of humanity's long battle with the
fungus Borlaug warned the scientists at
the meeting that the international
network of monitoring for wheat rest
needs to be strengthened and maintained
stem rust never sleeps it keeps changing
every day and night is unpredictable
often people only react to crises like
crop failures but given the importance
of wheat for feeding the world many
scientists hope that Borlaug's warning
will have a lasting effect this is Eric
stock stead with science magazine
you